em 1951 sua ampla disse que andar de
bicicleta fez mais pela emancipação da
mulher do que qualquer outra coisa no
mundo com as mulheres estão incluídas na
licitação
quem estava representando a mulher nos
planos de mobilidade que corte a
mobilidade porque as políticas públicas
não implementam ciclovias nas periferias
bom eu fui criado em uma família muito
negra feminina
minha avó dona edinho na costureira
empreendedora criou seis filhas de
família humilde e ouvir essas mulheres
crescendo e uma puxando a outra
eu comecei a pedalar em 2015
após o processo de cura após a perda do
meu pai
nesse processo de muita dor eu ficava
todo momento tentando rememorar coisas
boas que me remetia a bicicleta era uma
delas
eu me lembro ele dizendo vai que você
consegue
e nesse processo de muita dor luto
sozinha eu ia para pedais fé meninos
encontrava mulheres brancas e é para
pedais masculinos encontrava homens
brancos quais as narrativas perspectiva
de mundo eu não me conectava toda essa
inquietação juntamente com malu isabel
mulher negra periférica criamos uma frio
da barriga foi poético que a cafeteria
itinerante que leva café e poesia para
as ruas e se criar esse espaço
socialização e interação criação e
muitas mulheres negras se aproximava do
nosso bairro
nosso bairro e cafés que achava bom mas
o projeto de vocês mas ainda não sei pra
lá e era algo muito freqüente no ano
seguinte em 2016
já com a nova integrante do lacre da
bike james santana oitis a mulher
periférica
fomos um evento nacional de mobilidade e
de uma mesa debatendo sobre
queria mas não havia periferia lhe então
quando constatamos um novo protagonismo
das mulheres negras nos planos de
mobilidade bairro
as únicas negras daquela daquele dia
pinto éramos nós
esses debates ainda ficam mais distantes
quando percebemos que não existem
ciclovias nas periferias
não há integração e esse debate ainda
fica muito mais mais distante quando o
pai sabendo percebemos que o acesso a
bicicleta não é uma realidade da
população negra
aprendemos a pedra tardiamente não
sabemos pedalar não temos bicicleta seja
por questões econômicas ou repressões
diversas
então essa inquietação a gente tinha uma
certeza é preciso emagrecer os passos da
mobilidade incluir as mulheres negras
dos planos de mobilidade
voltamos pra salvador fizemos uma
pesquisa nesta pesquisa constatou que as
mulheres negras não estavam nos planos
de mobilidade bike porque não sabiam
pedalar
então ele foi até o facebook jogamos
ensinamos mulheres negras a pedra lá a
gente para o facebook esse dia e muitas
mulheres negras se aproximar e falar
preta como é que faz para pedalar
ele falou apresentar só vende bike e
criamos o projeto preta handbike projeto
preta vem de bike é uma ação da frida
que une promoção da bicicleta igualdade
ética igualdade de gênero onde a gente
visa levar a bicicleta para além da orla
as periferias
ganhamos uma bicicleta chamada
lucicreide rosinha baixinha mas pedalava
que só ela
o primeiro sentimento das minas e da
incapacidade do não conseguiu logo que
aprendem a idéia da capacidade de poder
libertação
logo após as aulas nós fazemos pedaladas
não só como forma de mostrar o resultado
mas também de ocupar os espaços públicos
é curioso que quando a gente faz as
pedaladas a galera acha que acha que
está fazendo alguma manifestação
afinal são tantas mulheres negras
pedalando na cidade e com quais ações do
preta das pedaladas a sony vai saber
algumas coisas que não só a gente estava
mexido com a mobilidade mas com
autonomia da
negra em uma casa de seis mulheres
há bicicletas e um meio de transporte da
casa que as coisas e econômica a
economia outro atrativo é a quando ela
baixa 7 40
a falta de mobilidade ela impede que as
mulheres roupa esses ciclos de pobreza
em possibilitando acesso há
possibilidades questões de saúde física
e mental
mulheres que venceram a depressão seguiu
sob pressão sobre peso e hoje são
triatleta questões econômica a nossa
periferia natal besa não se fala da
inclusão do esporte nas periferias
processo de recurso sonhos é a mesma
pesquisa nessa pesquisa constatou dentro
do peito além de bike que as mulheres
estavam aprendendo a pedalar porque é
uma realização de sonho e por que elas
não tinham bicicleta na infância porque
ela estava fazendo quando tinha dez 12
anos estava cuidando do irmão e quem
tinha bicicleta o irmão que é homem e
ela mais velha para quem foi da
bicicleta para o filho logo projeto
então só histórias que se repetem se
repetiam e processos de resistência
mulher negra pedalando na periferia no
centro são marcadores que não podem ser
ignorados
a capital mais negra do país é racista
a todo momento estamos pensando como
manter nossos corpos em movimento pedra
lá pra gente é um ato político em um ato
revolucionário
por mais que a pessoa que o pedagogo ela
não saiba mas ela está contribuindo para
a sociedade uma pessoa - do transporte
público é uma pessoa menos poluente do
planeta é da lá é um ato de resistência
ao status
por mais que não haja números
indicativos é cada vez maior o número de
mulheres negras periféricas pedalando
quando a gente fala que a emancipação da
mulher veio por meio da bicicleta quais
mulheres estão incluídas naquela
situação
as mulheres brancas porque as mulheres
negras estava lutando existir nas nossas
periferias nós encontramos nossa sigla
mortes é o governo dizendo o poder
público dizendo quem fica e quem morre
isto é genocídio do povo negro hoje a
bicicleta pra gente é uma forma da gente
gerar renda empregabilidade local
somos a primeira empresa de mecânica de
bicicleta feita por mulheres negras
e eu tenho certeza que o primeiro
pensamento do cliente é será que essas
meninas mães ou mesmo a cidade ela foi
construída uma perspectiva branca
os produtos também a todo momento não
estamos pensando em soluções como
incluir as mulheres negras e periférica
nos planos de mobilidade bike como
bicicleta mas rebaixadas bicicletas é
mais leves e capacete em forma de um
para cabelo crespo porque tal é além de
simplesmente andar de bicicleta é uma
coisa que eu queria quando criança mas
as oportunidades não surgiram
eu fui rodada de sonhar não sonhei muito
na minha vida onde eu fui criada uma
bicicleta mas não pôde usar dona elza
aluna do preta vem de bike 63 anos
revelando desse modo que a bicicleta ela
permeia processo de cura sonhos
autoestima e que está conectado tudo o
que aponte que a gente tem que
atravessar
ela é infinita obrigada